This is an I-Hart podcast. Guaranteed Human. The Hard Rock Bet Casino app is here, Ontario. And with a name like Hard Rock, you know you're in for an experience you can only get here. Exclusive games, an exclusive progressive jackpot, and the kind of trust and security you can only get with Hard Rock. And now you can enjoy the things you can only get here anywhere.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。Hard Rock Bet赌场应用程序现已登陆安大略省。有了Hard Rock这样的名字，您就知道您将获得一种只能在这里获得的体验。独家游戏、独家累积奖金，以及只有Hard Rock才能提供的信任和安全保障。现在，您可以随时随地享受这些只能在这里获得的体验。
Hard Rock Bed is here, Ontario. Download the app. Roll with us. Must be 19 years of age or older to play. Ontario only. Please play responsibly. Concerned about your gambling or that of someone close to you, visit connectsonterio.ca. I'm Melissa Jeltson, host of the What Happened to Her Podcast.
Hard Rock Bet现已登陆安大略省。下载应用程序。加入我们。必须年满19岁或以上方可参与。仅限安大略省。请负责任地博彩。如果您担心自己或身边人的赌博问题，请访问connectsonterio.ca。我是Melissa Jeltson，《她发生了什么事》(What Happened to Her)播客的主持人。
We're kicking off the season with the Sandra Birchmore story, a case the police rode off as a suicide in a snowstorm. Her family never bought it, and the man they suspected wore a badge. You never know who that devil is because he's wearing in disguise. Sometimes it's a police uniform. And you can get access to all episodes 100% ad-free with an I-heart, True Crime, Plus subscription exclusively on Apple Podcasts, available only to Iheart True Crime Plus subscribers. So don't wait, head to Apple Podcasts, search for IHeart True Crime Plus, and subscribe today. Lisa, tell them about our new show.
本季我们以Sandra Birchmore的故事开篇，警方将此案草草定性为暴风雪中的自杀。她的家人从未相信，而他们怀疑的那个人戴着警徽。你永远不知道那个恶魔是谁，因为他伪装了起来。有时是警察制服。您可以通过I-Heart True Crime Plus订阅，在Apple Podcasts上独家收听所有剧集，且100%无广告，仅限I-Heart True Crime Plus订阅者。所以别等了，前往Apple Podcasts，搜索I-Heart True Crime Plus并立即订阅。Lisa，告诉他们我们的新节目。
We have a new podcast. It's called Don't Lie to Me. I'm Lexi Yuwanu. We're two best friends, 22 years apart, but so close at heart. And I'm Lisa DiGulio, the old one, which means we have wildly different references, occasionally different opinions. and at this point in my 50s, I've lived it all. Now in my 30s, being the founder of new shoes, good taste is my business.
我们有一个新播客。它叫《别对我撒谎》(Don't Lie to Me)。我是Lexi Yuwanu。我们是两位最好的朋友，相差22岁，但心意相通。我是Lisa DiGulio，年长的那位，这意味着我们有截然不同的参考系，偶尔也有不同的观点。到了50多岁这个阶段，我什么都经历过了。而现在30多岁的我，作为新鞋的创始人，好品味就是我的事业。
Listen on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hi, this is Kylie Breakman. Angel Geratana. Jeremy Colhane. Patrick McDonald. And we're the hosts of the Artists on Artists on Artists on Artists Podcast. The Improvised Character Comedy Podcast
在I-HeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。嗨，我是Kylie Breakman。Angel Geratana。Jeremy Colhane。Patrick McDonald。我们是《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》(Artists on Artists on Artists on Artists)播客的主持人。这是一个即兴角色喜剧播客，
where each week a new panel of artists discuss their craft. Join us for a panel of Eurovision participants. And we do a little Halloween sometimes. Does the Pope dress up? He winks on Halloween. He gets right up next to the microphone. I hear you can almost hear the eyelashes hit each other. You never seen Italy so quiet as when the Pope gets up to wink on Halloween.
每周都有一个新的艺术家小组讨论他们的技艺。加入我们，一起听听欧洲歌唱大赛参赛者的小组讨论。我们有时也会做一点万圣节特辑。教皇会打扮吗？他在万圣节会眨眼。他会凑到麦克风旁边。我听说你几乎能听到睫毛碰撞的声音。你从未见过意大利像教皇在万圣节眨眼时那样安静。
Listen to Artists on Artists on Artists every Thursday on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Lacey Mosley, author, actor, stand-up comedian, creator, and host of Scam Goddess Podcast. comedy podcast all about robbery, fraud, and those who practice it. Each week I bring on an amazing guest. Ooh, I scammed them. What? I can talk to you for an hour. You're a generational yapper like me.
每周四在I-Heart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》。我是Lacey Mosley，作家、演员、单口喜剧演员、创作者，也是《骗子女神》(Scam Goddess)播客的主持人。这是一个关于抢劫、欺诈以及那些行骗之人的喜剧播客。每周我都会请来一位了不起的嘉宾。噢，我骗了他们。什么？我可以和你聊一个小时。你和我一样是个滔滔不绝的人。
That's why I had to make yapping a job. And now you can catch full episodes of my show on YouTube. Start listening to Scam Goddess on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody. I'm Jemis Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to this show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s and so much more.
这就是为什么我必须把这种滔滔不绝变成一份工作。现在您可以在YouTube上观看我节目的完整剧集。开始在I-Heart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《骗子女神》。大家好。我是Jemis Spike，欢迎回到《你20多岁的心理学》(The Psychology of Your 20s)，这是一个我们探讨20多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到这个节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听另一集，当然，我们要在这里剖析20多岁的心理学以及更多内容。
Today I have another debunking psychology bonus episode for you. If you are new here and new to this series twice a month, I like to take a break from talking about the psychology of our 20s and instead talk about a commonly used psychological phrase, term, concept, theory that has maybe been a little bit misconstrued by the internet or misconstrued by public perception and just tell you what it really means and take all the evidence, all the history, siphon it down and give you the exact facts. Last week we did the Stanford Prison Experiment. Before that, we did false memories. We did Stockholm Syndrome. Today, we are turning our sights to the placebo effect, which I would say is one of the most culturally borrowed phrases from psychology out there. What does it actually mean that?
今天我为您准备了另一期揭秘心理学奖金剧集。如果您是新听众，并且是第一次接触这个系列，每个月我会抽出两次时间，暂停讨论20多岁的心理学，转而讨论一个被互联网或公众认知可能稍微误解的常用心理学短语、术语、概念或理论，并告诉您它的真实含义，汇集所有证据和历史，将其提炼出来，给您确切的事实。上周我们讨论了斯坦福监狱实验。在那之前，我们讨论了虚假记忆。我们讨论了斯德哥尔摩综合症。今天，我们将目光转向安慰剂效应，我认为这是心理学中最常被文化借用的短语之一。它到底是什么意思？
When somebody says, oh, it's the placebo effect, when somebody references that maybe not even in a medical sense, just in a general sense, what are they talking about? There is so much weird history to this. For example, Benjamin Franklin gets involved. There are big ethical considerations. There are studies on depression, IBS, everything you can imagine, it is a massive part of psychology and psychology research, and I feel like you deserve to know what it really means. So without further ado, let's get into it. So the placebo effect is the phenomena where someone experiences an improvement in their physical and mental health symptoms after they have received a fake or inactive treatment or after they believe they have received a treatment that scientifically may not actually work. This can include things like when you get a sugar pill or a saline treatment or a false procedure, anything that doesn't contain an actual,
当有人说，哦，这是安慰剂效应时，当有人提到这一点时，甚至可能不是在医学意义上，只是在一般意义上，他们在谈论什么？这背后有太多奇怪的历史。例如，本杰明·富兰克林也参与其中。这里有重大的伦理考量。有关于抑郁症、肠易激综合症(IBS)以及你能想象到的所有方面的研究，它是心理学和心理学研究中非常重要的一部分，我觉得您有权知道它真正的含义。所以事不宜迟，让我们开始吧。安慰剂效应是一种现象，即某人在接受了虚假或无效的治疗后，或者在他们相信自己接受了治疗后，其身心健康症状出现了改善，而这种治疗在科学上可能实际上并不起作用。这可以包括诸如服用糖丸、生理盐水治疗或虚假手术等任何不包含实际成分的事物，
active ingredient sometimes still produces this effect. It still makes people get better. And scientists and psychologists have been trying to figure out why for a very long time. The idea of the placebo effect actually has a very long history. The word placebo comes from Latin. It roughly translates to I shall or I will please, which I think that's a beautiful way of like thinking about the placebo effect desired and wanting to please and wanting to see change whether it's going to happen or not. But one of the earliest experiments that basically recognized that this happens to us, that pure belief that something will work sometimes does actually create changes happened in the 1700s. In the 1700s, something weird was going on. There was this man, his name was Franz,
有时仍然会产生这种效果。它仍然能让人好转。科学家和心理学家很长一段时间以来一直试图找出原因。安慰剂效应的概念实际上有着悠久的历史。安慰剂(Placebo)一词来自拉丁语。它大致翻译为“我将取悦”，我认为这是一种看待安慰剂效应的美好方式，即渴望、想要取悦并想要看到变化，无论它是否会发生。但最早认识到这一点——即纯粹的信念有时确实会产生变化——的实验之一发生在18世纪。在18世纪，发生了一些奇怪的事情。有一个人，他的名字叫弗朗茨·
Anton Mesmer, he was in France, and he was promoting something that he called animal magnetism. He basically believed that there was an invisible magnetic fluid that flowed through the body, and illnesses resulted when that flow became disrupted. Now, he was kind of gently getting at something like electrical signals and the fact that we have nerve cells all down us, but he was a bit far off and his treatments were really, really wacky and very elaborate to say the least. It included things like he would get his patients to drink iron shavings, which is very dangerous,
安东·梅斯梅尔(Franz Anton Mesmer)，他在法国，他正在推广一种他称之为“动物磁性”的东西。他基本上认为有一种无形的磁流在体内流动，当这种流动受到干扰时，疾病就会产生。现在，他实际上是在隐约触及类似电信号的东西，以及我们全身都有神经细胞的事实，但他离真相还很远，而且他的治疗方法非常、非常古怪，至少可以说非常复杂。其中包括他会让病人喝铁屑，这非常危险，
and then he would literally use magnets to, as he would say, draw the illnesses out using the iron within them. And he quickly realized that he didn't even need to use them at all, magnets. If he just told people, if he just stared at people and said, and like waved his arms over them and said, I'm curing you. I'm realigning your fluids. Like I'm realigning your like how your energy travels. People would still have these intense reactions and they would see these massive improvements. And it became so popular that the king of France basically was like, somebody needs to get to the bottom of what this guy is talking about. And whether this is
然后他会用磁铁，正如他所说，利用其中的铁将疾病“吸”出来。他很快意识到他甚至根本不需要使用磁铁。如果他只是盯着人们，挥动双臂说，我正在治愈你。我正在重新调整你的体液。我正在重新调整你的能量流动方式。人们仍然会有强烈的反应，并且会看到巨大的改善。这变得非常流行，以至于法国国王基本上说，必须有人查清这家伙在说什么。以及这是否
is actually real, and so he assigned this group to investigate, one of them being Ben Franklin, one of the founding fathers of the United States. He was in France, and he was like, I need to check this out. And he was basically tasked with getting to the bottom of what was going on. So what they realized was in order to test if this theory was real, that people were being cured by an invisible magnetic field that this man, France, could manipulate with his hands. They had to, assess. They had to, essentially create a control group. They needed to actually administer the treatment that he was telling people he was administering. But then they also had to tell people they were administering the treatment and give them nothing. Or, you know, say that like this is the same thing that Franz
实际上是真的，于是他指派了一个小组进行调查，其中一人就是美国开国元勋之一的本·富兰克林。他在法国，他当时想，我需要调查一下。他基本上被委以查明真相的任务。所以他们意识到，为了测试这个理论是否真实，即人们是被这个男人弗朗茨用手操纵的无形磁场治愈的，他们必须进行评估。他们必须本质上创建一个对照组。他们需要实际执行他告诉人们他正在执行的治疗。但随后他们也必须告诉人们他们正在进行治疗，却什么也没给他们。或者，你知道，说这和弗朗茨
has given you and see if they were having the same reactions to basically tell whether what he was doing was actually special or whether it was just this belief. They figured out very quickly that Franz wasn't doing anything special. People were just so willing to feel differently and so willing to see results that some part of them seemed to make the results appear, either by making them up for themselves or by making them up for other people. And it was kind of hard to distinguish what it was, but they were seeing and they were feeling differently. And so this is when the term placebo effect came to be, to describe. To describe. this phenomena. Another early example came from a treatment known as Perkins tractors. It sounds awful.
给你的东西是一样的，看看他们是否会有同样的反应，以此来判断他所做的事情是否真的特别，或者仅仅是这种信念。他们很快发现弗朗茨并没有做什么特别的事情。人们只是太渴望感觉不同，太渴望看到结果，以至于他们的一部分似乎让结果出现了，要么是为自己编造，要么是为别人编造。很难区分到底是什么，但他们确实看到了，也感觉到了不同。所以这就是“安慰剂效应”一词的由来，用来描述这种现象。另一个早期例子来自一种被称为“珀金斯牵引器”(Perkins tractors)的治疗方法。听起来很糟糕。
Actually, it kind of was awful. These were this pair of like small metal rods that had been invented by this American doctor called Dr. Alicia, I think Elijah Perkins. And the idea was that these metal rods, very similar to the previous idea, could be drawn over certain parts of the body. And the metal would attract the pain. The metals could relieve illness by drawing away a harmful electoral influence from the body. Now, people promoted these for a whole range of things. Headaches, toothaches, chronic illnesses. And they even got these really popular doctors at the time to basically say, these things work. This is the new. This is how we're going to cure all pain. So imagine like Dr. Phil, like Dr. Oz being like, this is my number one thing. Obviously,
事实上，它确实很糟糕。这是一对小金属棒，由一位名叫艾丽西亚（我想是伊莱贾·珀金斯）的美国医生发明。其理念是，这些金属棒与之前的想法非常相似，可以在身体的某些部位上滑动。金属会吸引疼痛。金属可以通过从身体中吸走有害的电影响来缓解疾病。现在，人们推广这些东西用于各种各样的事情。头痛、牙痛、慢性病。他们甚至让当时那些非常受欢迎的医生基本上说，这些东西有效。这是新的。这就是我们将治愈所有疼痛的方法。所以想象一下像菲尔博士、奥兹医生那样说，这是我的头号产品。显然，
he got a lot of money from that and he got a lot of popularity. People obviously became skeptical and so they did the same thing. They looked back to this previous time where this had happened and they were like, we need to just see if this is actually working or whether it's again this placebo effect we've been talking about. And so they created a fake prototype made of wood. And again, what they noticed was that when they told the people it was those metal tractors, it wasn't, but the outcome was still the same. So after so many stories like that, this. Scientists were like, we have a bit of a problem because we have been prescribing people things and we have been administering treatments and are we actually testing if they are working or are we
他从中赚了很多钱，也获得了很高的人气。人们显然变得怀疑起来，所以他们做了同样的事情。他们回顾了之前发生这种情况的时候，他们想，我们需要看看这是否真的有效，或者它是否又是我们一直在谈论的安慰剂效应。于是他们制造了一个木制的假原型。同样，他们注意到，当他们告诉人们那是金属牵引器时（其实不是），结果仍然是一样的。所以在经历了这么多这样的故事之后，科学家们想，我们遇到了一个问题，因为我们一直在给人们开药，一直在进行治疗，我们到底是在测试它们是否有效，还是在
just testing somebody's belief in the fact that they can work? And is their belief what is changing their outcomes? This really kind of came to a head in like the 1900s, specifically after the release of a very famous paper in 1950. This paper was published by Harry Beecher. He was a Harvard investigator and anisologist. I can never say that word anesthesiologist. Oh, I just did. Anyways, that's what he did. And he wrote this paper called the powerful placebo. This paper basically went viral in today's terms. And in it, he looked at data from across 15 studies and estimated that 35% of patients in that study or in these collection of studies improved from the placebo effect alone. One in three people.
仅仅测试某人对它们能起作用的信念？是他们的信念在改变他们的结果吗？这在20世纪，特别是在1950年发表了一篇非常著名的论文后，真正达到了顶峰。这篇论文由哈里·比彻(Harry Beecher)发表。他是哈佛大学的研究员和麻醉学家。我永远说不出那个词，麻醉学家。哦，我刚才说了。总之，这就是他的工作。他写了这篇名为《强大的安慰剂》(The Powerful Placebo)的论文。这篇论文在今天看来基本上是病毒式传播的。在文中，他查看了15项研究的数据，估计这些研究或研究集合中35%的患者仅因安慰剂效应而好转。三分之一的人。
nothing about their condition changed other than that they took this fake or false medication and their belief seemed to have an influence. That is a lot of people. And so this is when scientists really were like, we need a group, a placebo group or a control group, and we need an experimental group to distinguish what is actually happening. That is now a central pillar in so much scientific research. So what is actually happening? How does this happen? So, a placebo drug, a placebo treatment, it's not going to shrink a tumor, it's not going to fix a broken leg. But what it can do is work on symptoms that are modulated by the brain. Specifically, as one Harvard article put it, they can work on our perception. Their effect on our expectations
除了他们服用了这种虚假或伪造的药物外，他们的病情没有任何变化，而他们的信念似乎产生了影响。那是很多人。所以这就是科学家们真正意识到的时候，我们需要一个安慰剂组或对照组，我们需要一个实验组来区分到底发生了什么。这现在是许多科学研究的核心支柱。那么到底发生了什么？这是怎么发生的？所以，安慰剂药物、安慰剂治疗，它不会缩小肿瘤，也不会修复骨折的腿。但它能做的是作用于由大脑调节的症状。具体来说，正如哈佛大学的一篇文章所言，它们可以作用于我们的感知。它们对我们期望的影响
and the way our expectations go on to inform our reality is probably the easiest way to see this. If we expect a treatment to ease the pain we're feeling, that is going to influence how we're our brain interprets that sense of pain. It's not to say that thinking, this won't hurt, I'll be fine, we'll simply switch off any pain we might feel, but pain isn't always a reliable indication of some of like specific physical damage. A lot of it is mental. People experience pain differently. They could have the same level of break. They could have the same exact injury, but their psychological reaction to it, their pain tolerance, their mental reaction to it will change their threshold, not their threshold, but will change how the pain is felt.
以及我们的期望如何去塑造我们的现实，可能是看到这一点最简单的方法。如果我们期望一种治疗能缓解我们感到的疼痛，那就会影响我们的大脑如何解读那种疼痛感。这并不是说认为“这不会痛，我会没事的”就能简单地消除我们可能感到的任何疼痛，但疼痛并不总是某种特定身体损伤的可靠指标。很大一部分是心理上的。人们对疼痛的体验不同。他们可能遭受同样程度的骨折。他们可能遭受完全相同的伤害，但他们对它的心理反应、他们的疼痛耐受力、他们对它的心理反应会改变他们的阈值，不是阈值，而是会改变疼痛的感觉方式。
Pain is a construction of the nervous system. That's basically what we're saying. It uses signals from the body, of course, but it also uses signals from our attention, from our emotions, from our memory, from previous experiences of pain, and from our attitude towards the pain. It is a combination of both tangible physical thing that is happening to us and our mental interpretation of it. So if we change our expectations about the experience of pain, that might change how we feel it. In 2014, they did the study looking at migraine treatment. And participants were either given a real migraine drug. It's called maxalt or a placebo drug during their migraine attacks. The drug wasn't the only thing the researchers changed.
疼痛是神经系统的构建。这基本上就是我们要说的。它当然使用来自身体的信号，但它也使用来自我们的注意力、情绪、记忆、以往的疼痛经历以及我们对疼痛态度的信号。它是发生在我们身上的有形物理事物和我们对其心理诠释的结合。所以如果我们改变对疼痛体验的期望，那可能会改变我们的感受。2014年，他们做了一项关于偏头痛治疗的研究。参与者在偏头痛发作期间要么被给予真正的偏头痛药物。它叫Maxalt，要么被给予安慰剂药物。药物并不是研究人员改变的唯一东西。
They also told the participants different things. They told the patients that they were getting the real drug, that maybe they would either get the real drug or the fake drug, or that sometimes they were just going to get the fake drug, but they weren't going to tell them which. What they found was that putting more positive labeling on the drug positively boosted the efficacy of both the real medication and the placebo. So when they said this drug that we could potentially be giving you as the best line of treatment, it is number one. even though they knew there was a possibility they got the fake treatment and even though some of them did, they still felt better because the pain, it felt like it was being taken care of and therefore maybe required less attention. It felt like the best thing they could possibly do was already happening.
他们还告诉参与者不同的事情。他们告诉病人他们得到的是真正的药物，或者他们可能得到真正的药物或假药，或者有时他们只是会得到假药，但他们不会告诉他们是哪一种。他们发现，对药物进行更积极的标签化，积极地提升了真实药物和安慰剂的疗效。所以当他们说这种我们可能给你的药物是最好的治疗方案，它是第一名时，即使他们知道他们有可能得到假药，即使他们中的一些人确实得到了，他们仍然感觉更好，因为疼痛，感觉它正在被处理，因此可能需要更少的关注。感觉就像他们能做的最好的事情已经发生了。
This can also work in the opposite direction. If somebody expects a treatment to cause nausea, to cause headaches, to cause side effects, they also may be more likely, sorry, to explain those symptoms as well. This is called the nocebo effect. Here's an example of this for you. In 2007, a 26-year-old man enrolled in an antidepressant trial and he swallowed 29 capsules because I guess he thought if I do it all at once, it's definitely going to work like go big or go home. I really don't want to be depressed anymore. Now he said I didn't want to overdose. That wasn't my intention. I just really wanted this to get this over with. I really wanted to feel better. But he grew concerned. He was a bit worried. You know, he read the label and it said, don't take them all at once. And so he went to the
这也可以在相反的方向起作用。如果某人期望一种治疗会导致恶心、头痛、副作用，他们也可能更有可能，抱歉，也会解释这些症状。这被称为反安慰剂效应(Nocebo effect)。这里有一个例子。2007年，一名26岁的男子参加了一项抗抑郁药试验，他吞下了29粒胶囊，因为我想他认为如果我一次性全部服用，它肯定会起作用，要么做大，要么回家。我真的不想再抑郁了。现在他说我不想过量服用。那不是我的意图。我只是真的想尽快结束这一切。我真的想感觉好一点。但他开始担心。他有点担心。你知道，他读了标签，上面写着，不要一次全部服用。所以他去了
hospital. And when he got there, his blood pressure was through the roof. His heart rate was insanely high. He needed IV fluids. His body was showing signs of basically shut down. And the hospital was like, we need to call the people who are involved in this trial and figure out what he's taken because otherwise we don't know how to treat it. And they call them up and they go, we need to know he's really not doing well. and they said, well, that's really strange because we gave him the placebo. There's no active substance in that drug that he took. And he was told that. They said, don't worry.
医院。当他到达那里时，他的血压高得惊人。他的心率极高。他需要静脉注射液体。他的身体表现出基本上崩溃的迹象。医院说，我们需要打电话给参与这项试验的人，弄清楚他服用了什么，否则我们不知道如何治疗。他们打电话给他们，他们说，我们需要知道他真的情况不好。他们说，嗯，这真的很奇怪，因为我们给他的是安慰剂。他服用的那种药里没有活性物质。而且他被告知了这一点。他们说，别担心。
That was just a placebo. And his symptoms rapidly subsided. Within about 15 minutes, his blood pressure, his heart rate, all returned to pretty much their normal levels, but also other indicators. And you might think, well, that's because he feels calm now. This was all psychological. Some parts of it weren't psychological. Some parts of it were, like, that were deeply biological and things that you can't mentally
那只是安慰剂。他的症状迅速消退。大约15分钟内，他的血压、心率都恢复到了几乎正常的水平，还有其他指标。你可能会想，嗯，那是因为他现在感觉平静了。这全是心理上的。有些部分不是心理上的。有些部分是，比如，那些深深的生物学上的东西，以及你不能在心理上
change about yourself based on perception. Like, your body has to do that for you. This obviously provided, like, a very striking example about how our expectations of harm can also influence how our mind and our body responds to a medication we're taking or a treatment or something that's just happening to us. Another potential mechanism behind the effect of the placebo is not just expectations, it's conditioning. Many of us have years and years of experience linking certain things with feeling better. You take a panadol, the pain goes away.
改变自己的东西，基于感知。比如，你的身体必须为你做这件事。这显然提供了一个非常引人注目的例子，说明我们对伤害的期望如何也能影响我们的思想和身体对我们正在服用的药物、治疗或仅仅是发生在我们身上的事情的反应。安慰剂效应背后的另一个潜在机制不仅仅是期望，还有条件反射。我们许多人有多年将某些事物与感觉好转联系起来的经验。你服用一片必理痛(Panadol)，疼痛就消失了。
Your parents put a band-aid on your boo-boo, like suddenly it feels a lot better. You have a bath, your fever subsides, like all these little things that have worked in the past and now we begin to link them. After years of doing this sequence, after years of taking the tablet, the headache going away, getting a cold compress, seeing the pain subside, things associated with the treatment like the pill, the taste of the medicine, the setting, the feeling can become cues that tell our brain to feel better. The expectation of treatment, the sense that we are feeling taken care of, that we are taking care of the problem appears to actually trigger activity in the biological systems already present in the body. An inactive pill is not going to kill bacteria in the same way that an antibiotic will. Expecting a broken bone to heal faster won't physically speed up your recovery. But what we are seeing is that when you feel like something
你的父母在你的伤口上贴上创可贴，突然感觉好多了。你洗个澡，发烧消退了，所有这些过去有效的小事，现在我们开始将它们联系起来。经过多年的这种序列，经过多年的服用药片、头痛消失、使用冷敷、看到疼痛消退，与治疗相关的事物，如药丸、药物的味道、环境、感觉，都可以成为告诉我们大脑感觉好转的线索。对治疗的期望，感觉到我们正在被照顾，感觉到我们正在处理问题，似乎实际上触发了体内已经存在的生物系统的活动。一颗无效的药丸不会像抗生素那样杀死细菌。期望骨折愈合得更快不会在物理上加速你的恢复。但我们看到的是，当你觉得某事
is being taken care of, when you are receiving the treatment, the supportiveness of that, The fact that there is a level of stress taken away with feeling like you don't have to worry about this thing, that something in your body behind the scenes is sorting it out does seem to put your body in your mind and all your systems in a better state for healing. The ritual of treatment, the ritual of feeling listened to as well, especially when a doctor is involved or a GP or something, just the experience of being cared. for can influence things like how we perceive our symptoms, how we perceive our symptoms, a level of anxiety, and our body on a whole, its ability to regulate itself and put itself into rest and repair mode, and therefore, yeah, perhaps heal us faster, even if a truly effective
正在被处理时，当你正在接受治疗时，那种支持性，那种因为觉得你不必担心这件事而减轻了压力水平的事实，那种你身体里幕后的某些东西正在解决它的事实，似乎确实让你的身体、你的思想和你的所有系统处于更好的愈合状态。治疗的仪式，被倾听的感觉的仪式，特别是当医生或全科医生参与时，仅仅是被照顾的体验，就可以影响诸如我们如何感知症状、我们如何感知症状、焦虑水平，以及我们的身体作为一个整体，其自我调节并进入休息和修复模式的能力，因此，是的，也许能让我们愈合得更快，即使是一种真正有效的
treatment isn't entirely present. In a study from 2008 from researchers at Harvard Medical School, they really demonstrated this effect quite well with a group of patients who had IBS, Irritable Bow Syndrome. Two groups received the same treatment, the exact same treatment. But in one group, the practitioner who administered the treatment was really, really nice, really, really warm, listened actively, expressed confidence in the treatment, and in the other, the practitioner was really cold and rude and brief. Same treatment. But the group with the warm, attentive person reported significantly greater symptom relief and an improved quality of life. And I think that human connection component itself, like that is a powerful
治疗并不完全存在。在哈佛医学院研究人员2008年的一项研究中，他们在一组患有肠易激综合症(IBS)的患者身上很好地证明了这种效应。两组接受了相同的治疗，完全相同的治疗。但在其中一组中，实施治疗的医生非常、非常友善，非常、非常热情，积极倾听，对治疗表示信心，而在另一组中，医生非常冷漠、粗鲁且简短。同样的治疗。但那个有热情、专注的人的小组报告了明显更大的症状缓解和改善的生活质量。我认为那种人际联系本身，那是一个强大的
clinical intervention. That is a powerful part of feeling better. So I want to take a short break, but then I want to discuss if the placebo effect wears off eventually. You know, is there a timeline? Is there a, I guess, a deadline on how long this feeling or this, the impact of belief or delusion can make us feel better? We're going to explore that. And I also want to explore how we can use the known placebo effect to change our behavior and to manipulate ourselves. Stay with us.
临床干预。那是感觉好转的一个强大组成部分。所以我想休息一下，但之后我想讨论安慰剂效应最终是否会消失。你知道，有一个时间表吗？对于这种感觉或这种信念或错觉的影响能让我们感觉好转多久，有一个截止日期吗？我们将探讨这个问题。我也想探讨我们如何利用已知的安慰剂效应来改变我们的行为并操纵我们自己。请留下来。
The Hard Rock Beck Casino app is now in Ontario. The name you know and trust, which means credibility, impeccable 24-7 customers, Support and an easy to use app are also here. So you can play here, there, anywhere. The Hard Rockback Casino app is now in Ontario. Download the app. Roll with us. Must be 19 years of age or older to play. Ontario only. Please play responsibly.
Hard Rock Bet赌场应用程序现已登陆安大略省。您所知和信任的名字，意味着信誉、无可挑剔的24/7客户支持和易于使用的应用程序也已来到这里。所以您可以在这里、那里、任何地方玩。Hard Rock Bet赌场应用程序现已登陆安大略省。下载应用程序。加入我们。必须年满19岁或以上方可参与。仅限安大略省。请负责任地博彩。
Concerned about your gambling or that of someone close to you, visit connectsonterio.ca. I'm Melissa Jeltson, host of the What Happened to Her podcast. We're kicking off the season with the Sandra Birchmore story, a case the police. rode off as a suicide in a snowstorm. Her family never bought it, and the man they suspected wore a badge. You never know who that devil is because he's wearing in disguise. Sometimes it's a police uniform. And you can get access to all episodes 100% ad-free with an Iheart True Crime Plus subscription
如果您担心自己或身边人的赌博问题，请访问connectsonterio.ca。我是Melissa Jeltson，《她发生了什么事》播客的主持人。本季我们以Sandra Birchmore的故事开篇，警方将此案草草定性为暴风雪中的自杀。她的家人从未相信，而他们怀疑的那个人戴着警徽。你永远不知道那个恶魔是谁，因为他伪装了起来。有时是警察制服。您可以通过I-Heart True Crime Plus订阅，在Apple Podcasts上独家收听所有剧集，
exclusively on Apple Podcasts, available only to Iheart True Crime Plus subscribers. So don't wait, head to Apple Podcasts, search for IHeart True Crime Plus, and subscribe today. Lisa, we should tell them about our new show. Oh my god, Lexi. We have a new podcast. It's called Don't Lie to Me. I'm Lexi Iwano. We're two best friends, 22 years apart, but so close at heart. And I'm Lisa Di Giulio, the old one, which means we have wildly different references, occasionally different opinions, and at this point in my 50s, I've lived it all. I'm not going to get anyone fighting. That is wild. I learned that about you today. Now in my 30s, being the founder of new shoes, good taste is my business.
仅限I-Heart True Crime Plus订阅者。所以别等了，前往Apple Podcasts，搜索I-Heart True Crime Plus并立即订阅。Lisa，我们应该告诉他们我们的新节目。天哪，Lexi。我们有一个新播客。它叫《别对我撒谎》。我是Lexi Iwano。我们是两位最好的朋友，相差22岁，但心意相通。我是Lisa Di Giulio，年长的那位，这意味着我们有截然不同的参考系，偶尔也有不同的观点，到了50多岁这个阶段，我什么都经历过了。我不会让任何人吵架。那太疯狂了。我今天才了解到你这一点。而现在30多岁的我，作为新鞋的创始人，好品味就是我的事业。
And I've always got something to say. If men were just honest about this, there would be so much more peace in the world. We're going to talk about dating, relationships, beauty, getting older, and a little wiser. We're best friends, but we don't always agree. Because you told us how accommodating you are. Obviously, I would do what I think I could do to fight the fight, but there's only so much fight I can fight. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me.
而且我总是有话要说。如果男人们对此诚实一点，世界会和平得多。我们将讨论约会、关系、美容、变老，以及变得更聪明一点。我们是最好的朋友，但我们并不总是同意对方。因为你告诉我们你有多么随和。显然，我会做我认为我能做的事去抗争，但抗争是有极限的。别对我撒谎。别对我撒谎。
Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Liar. Listen on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. I don't really care. Hi, this is Kylie Breakman.
别对我撒谎。别对我撒谎。别对我撒谎。别对我撒谎。骗子。在I-Heart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。我真的不在乎。嗨，我是Kylie Breakman。
Angel Geratana. Jeremy Colhane. Patrick McDonald. And we're the hosts of the Artists on Artists on Artists on Artists Podcast. The Improvised Character Comedy Podcast where each week a new panel of artists discuss their craft. Join us for a panel of wellness influencers. What I try to do is faux journal. I don't know.
Angel Geratana。Jeremy Colhane。Patrick McDonald。我们是《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》播客的主持人。这是一个即兴角色喜剧播客，每周都有一个新的艺术家小组讨论他们的技艺。加入我们，一起听听健康影响者的小组讨论。我尝试做的是伪日记。我不知道。
Have you guys heard of faux journaling? Yeah, it's reading. It's called reading. So we don't like to use that word anymore. Okay. A panel of New Yorker cartoonists. Have you guys done Terry Gross's Peloton class? No!
你们听说过伪日记吗？是的，那是阅读。它叫阅读。所以我们不喜欢再用那个词了。好的。一个《纽约客》漫画家小组。你们做过Terry Gross的Peloton课程吗？没有！
I've been dying too. I'm so sorry. I'm seeing a reading of Sadako and the Thousand Paper Cranes by Audra McDonald's at the Wonderland Bookstore. That's crazy. I went to the Wonderland Bookstore yesterday, and I heard Nora Jones do a reading of Zero Dark 30. No way. You have to come to the last bookstore, though. Kim Cottrell is reading the guitar tabs of yesterday.
我一直想做。我很抱歉。我正在Wonderland书店看Audra McDonald朗读《佐佐子与一千只纸鹤》(Sadako and the Thousand Paper Cranes)。那太疯狂了。我昨天去了Wonderland书店，我听到Nora Jones朗读《猎杀本·拉登》(Zero Dark 30)。不会吧。你一定要来最后一家书店(The Last Bookstore)。Kim Cottrell正在朗读《Yesterday》的吉他谱。
A panel of Eurovision participants. And we do a little Halloween sometimes. Does the Pope dress up? He winks on Halloween. He gets right up next to the microphone. I hear you can almost hear the eyelashes hit each other. You never seen Italy so quiet as when the Pope gets up to wink on Halloween. Listen to artists on artists on artists on the I-Hurt Radio.
一个欧洲歌唱大赛参赛者小组。我们有时也会做一点万圣节特辑。教皇会打扮吗？他在万圣节会眨眼。他会凑到麦克风旁边。我听说你几乎能听到睫毛碰撞的声音。你从未见过意大利像教皇在万圣节眨眼时那样安静。在I-Heart Radio收听《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》，
Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Lacey Mosley, author, actor, stand-up comedian, creator, and host of Scam Goddess Podcasts. The True Crime Comedy Podcasts all about robbery, fraud, and those who practice it. Each week I bring on incredible guests like Conan O'Brien, Iowa Deppery, Lamorne Morris, and Nicole Beyer. Ooh, I scammed them. What?
Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。我是Lacey Mosley，作家、演员、单口喜剧演员、创作者，也是《骗子女神》播客的主持人。这是一个关于抢劫、欺诈以及那些行骗之人的真实犯罪喜剧播客。每周我都会请来不可思议的嘉宾，比如Conan O'Brien、Ayo Edebiri、Lamorne Morris和Nicole Beyer。噢，我骗了他们。什么？
I can talk to you for a hour. You're a generational yapper like me. That's why I had to make yapping a job. And the scams run the gamut. I'm talking about scammer. from the 1800s all the way up to today. I also warn you and keep you safe against scammers. Call your grandparents.
我可以和你聊一个小时。你和我一样是个滔滔不绝的人。这就是为什么我必须把这种滔滔不绝变成一份工作。而且骗局五花八门。我说的是从1800年代一直到今天的骗子。我也警告您并保护您免受骗子的伤害。给你的祖父母打电话。
Tell your parents to stop clicking on links, please. And now you can catch full episodes of my show on YouTube. If there's a scam, I'm here to protect you. And I'm also here to laugh with you. So if you like fun, if you like comedy and you like learning and protecting yourself from criminals, start listening to scam goddess on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever. you get your podcast. So we have a lot of evidence that the placebo effect does exist and does produce a change in almost every single illness, every single area of medical investigation,
告诉你的父母停止点击链接，拜托。现在您可以在YouTube上观看我节目的完整剧集。如果有骗局，我在这里保护您。我也在这里和您一起欢笑。所以如果您喜欢乐趣，如果您喜欢喜剧，并且您喜欢学习并保护自己免受罪犯的伤害，开始在I-Heart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何地方收听《骗子女神》。所以我们有很多证据表明安慰剂效应确实存在，并且在几乎每一个疾病、每一个医学调查领域都产生了变化，
the placebo effect is known and is reported on. But how long does that change actually last for? There is a very important distinction between changing a symptom and changing the thing that's causing that symptom. A placebo might reduce pain, but it's not repairing the damaged tissue producing the pain. It might alter how breathless somebody feels, but it's not actually opening their narrowed airways. It might temporarily increase dopamine activity because of belief, but it doesn't change, you know, an underlying biological explanation for depression or for Parkinson's disease or for any number of conditions, diseases, or impairments. The underlying cause is still there. And eventually, if it's not being treated, like the placebo does wear out.
安慰剂效应是众所周知的，并且有相关报道。但这种变化到底能持续多久？在改变症状和改变导致该症状的事物之间有一个非常重要的区别。安慰剂可能会减轻疼痛，但它并没有修复产生疼痛的受损组织。它可能会改变某人呼吸困难的感觉，但它并没有真正打开他们狭窄的气道。它可能会因为信念而暂时增加多巴胺活性，但它不会改变，你知道，抑郁症或帕金森病或任何数量的疾病、病症或损伤的潜在生物学解释。根本原因仍然存在。而且最终，如果它没有得到治疗，安慰剂效应确实会消失。
The thing is, a lot of our research on the placebo effect is really short term. It's often minutes, hours, weeks, very rarely more than a few months, because after a while, it's really unethical to keep someone on a placebo if there is a proven real drug that can help them. Take, for example, that depression trial with that 20-year-old guy who overdosed. Again, he didn't overdose deliberately, but you don't do a trial like that unless you need help and unless you are desperate. Even if you are seeing some effects from the placebo, at some stage, if you see that the drug is also working or not working, you can't keep people from a legitimate treatment.
问题是，我们关于安慰剂效应的许多研究都是非常短期的。通常是几分钟、几小时、几周，很少超过几个月，因为过了一段时间，如果有一种经过验证的真实药物可以帮助他们，继续让某人服用安慰剂是非常不道德的。以那个服用过量的那位20岁男子的抑郁症试验为例。同样，他不是故意过量服用的，但除非你需要帮助并且绝望，否则你不会进行那样的试验。即使你从安慰剂中看到了一些效果，在某个阶段，如果你看到药物也有效或无效，你不能阻止人们获得合法的治疗。
That would be pretty awful. Unless you tell them that it's a placebo and they agree, to the possibility. Think about this in terms of like cancer drug trials for people who are like at the end of their lives and really need like a bit of a Hail Mary or people with motor neuron disease or any of those things where it's like trial drugs are some of their last resorts. There are a lot of ethical complications with knowing half the people participating are just going to be the dummy guinea pig group and that you believe enough in this drug to have put it into it, like to be testing it. You already know there is some
那会非常糟糕。除非你告诉他们那是安慰剂，并且他们同意这种可能性。想想癌症药物试验，对于那些处于生命尽头、真的需要一点“万福玛利亚”(Hail Mary)机会的人，或者患有运动神经元疾病的人，或者任何那些试验药物是他们最后手段之一的情况。知道参与的一半人只是作为虚拟的豚鼠组，而你对这种药物有足够的信念，以至于把它投入其中，比如去测试它，这有很多伦理上的复杂性。你已经知道有一些
evidence for it to for even a second, perhaps not give somebody that life-saving treatment or medication can be pretty brutal. And even if they know it's the conditions of the experiment, I think, you know, there's a lot of limits to doing that and it can just get very blurry, very, very quickly. What they now do is that they still do placebo trials, but they do it in a very specific way. It's called open label placebo procedure. And it is where people explicitly know that they might be receiving a placebo and they are told that this is part of how they're going to measure this. So basically, they are informed.
证据表明，甚至有一秒钟可能不给某人那种救命的治疗或药物，这可能非常残酷。即使他们知道这是实验的条件，我想，你知道，这样做有很多限制，而且它很快就会变得非常模糊。他们现在所做的是，他们仍然进行安慰剂试验，但他们以一种非常具体的方式进行。这被称为“开放标签安慰剂程序”(Open label placebo procedure)。在这种程序中，人们明确知道他们可能正在接受安慰剂，并且被告知这是他们将如何衡量这一点的一部分。所以基本上，他们是被告知的。
What they typically didn't want to do in the past was tell people that there was even an option for them to receive a placebo because they thought that would show the effect more. Nowadays, they'll often say there is a chance that you actually aren't going to be getting any treatment. And obviously that maybe changes some of the results, but it's a lot nicer to tell people that. And even then, even when they know, they could be taking a placebo, they do still see improvements. There was a 2010 study involving people with, again, with IBS. And even though they were taking pills openly labeled as potentially placebo pills, they still felt better than people receiving no treatment at all. Whatever was happening doesn't entirely depend on even deception.
他们过去通常不想做的是告诉人们他们甚至可以选择接受安慰剂，因为他们认为这会更显现出效果。如今，他们通常会说，你实际上可能根本得不到任何治疗。显然，这也许会改变一些结果，但告诉人们这一点要好得多。即便如此，即使当他们知道他们可能正在服用安慰剂时，他们仍然看到了改善。2010年有一项研究涉及患有肠易激综合症(IBS)的人。即使他们服用的是公开标记为可能是安慰剂药丸的药丸，他们仍然感觉比那些根本没有接受治疗的人好。无论发生了什么，甚至不完全依赖于欺骗。
Like, even them knowing that they could be deceived, the slight possibility that maybe they aren't being deceived seems to still have an effect. You know, as I said, it's hard to see the long-term effects of the placebo effect because normally research like that is going to get shut down. But one of the best examples of how long the placebo effect might last, has been revealed recently and it came from a 2023 study on lower back pain. The researchers followed up with people who had previously taken a placebo and they assessed them three years later and what they found was that after a while the effects of receiving even a dud treatment wore off. There was no evidence that there had been a lasting benefit
就像，即使他们知道他们可能会被欺骗，那种可能没有被欺骗的微小可能性似乎仍然有效果。你知道，正如我所说，很难看到安慰剂效应的长期影响，因为通常那样的研究会被叫停。但安慰剂效应可能持续多久的最佳例子之一最近被揭示出来，它来自2023年关于下背痛的一项研究。研究人员对之前服用过安慰剂的人进行了随访，并在三年后对他们进行了评估，他们发现过了一段时间，即使是接受无效治疗的效果也会消失。没有证据表明存在持久的益处。
compared with the control group. So the original short-horting, term success of feeling like you're being taken care of, feeling like things are getting better, has a shelf life. It doesn't translate into a lasting improvement. So that is probably the most critical part of this. We know a placebo effect does exist, but there is a deadline. There is a, there, it's a bit of a ticking clock as to how long it is going to before the body. And I think also the mind catches on. There is so much that there's only so much that we can psychologically trick ourselves into believing and there's only so much that our body can feel motivated to do in the in the face of treatment or feeling like it's receiving treatment before it realizes, hey, actually like nothing is
与对照组相比。所以最初的短期成功感，即感觉自己得到了照顾，感觉事情正在好转，是有保质期的。它并不能转化为持久的改善。所以这可能是其中最关键的部分。我们知道安慰剂效应确实存在，但它有一个截止日期。这有点像是一个倒计时，身体需要多长时间才能意识到这一点。我认为大脑也会意识到这一点。我们能在心理上欺骗自己去相信的东西是有限的，在面对治疗或感觉自己正在接受治疗时，我们的身体能感受到的动力也是有限的，直到它意识到，嘿，实际上什么都没有
changing for me biologically. I'm not getting more resources. Like nothing is actually helping me here. And we see a dip. We see that the effect wears off. Regardless of this, though, the placebo effect can still be helpful in some areas. Some areas beyond medical intervention. What I'm talking about is how we can use the placebo effect to make stuff happen for ourselves, to make us believe that things are working out for us, and to actually help us be more successful and achieve our dreams. We've spoken about the placebo effect only in terms of medications and only
在生物学上为我带来改变。我并没有获得更多的资源。这里实际上没有任何东西在帮助我。我们看到了一个下滑。我们看到这种效应逐渐消失。尽管如此，安慰剂效应在某些领域仍然是有帮助的。在医疗干预之外的一些领域。我所说的是我们如何利用安慰剂效应来促成事情的发生，让我们相信事情正在朝着对我们有利的方向发展，并真正帮助我们取得更大的成功，实现我们的梦想。我们之前只在药物方面谈论过安慰剂效应，也只
in terms of medical interventions. But all the principles underlying how the placebo effect does seem to show results or changes in behavior can be applied to things like exercise and productivity and audacity and goal setting. And I want to explain how do we use the placebo effect in our favor? The first thing is to remember that your expectations change your reality. We are seeing this in a medical setting, we can also see it in a personal setting. If you manipulate your expectations before your expectations manipulate you, you can create an outcome through self-belief that is more preferred. Your brain is constantly making predictions about what something is going to feel like, what something is going to be like. And those predictions influence the experience
在医疗干预方面谈论过。但安慰剂效应似乎能产生结果或行为改变的所有基本原则，都可以应用于运动、生产力、胆识和目标设定等方面。我想解释一下我们如何利用安慰剂效应为自己服务？第一件事是记住你的期望会改变你的现实。我们在医疗环境中看到了这一点，我们也可以在个人环境中看到它。如果你在期望操纵你之前先操纵你的期望，你就可以通过自我信念创造一个更理想的结果。你的大脑不断地对某件事的感觉、某件事的样子做出预测。而这些预测会影响体验
itself. We make these predictions all the time. The workout is going to be awful. I'm going to be so anxious at this party. This thing I have to do today is going to leave me exhausted. And typically, it's hard to prove that wrong once our brain believes it. You don't need to replace those thoughts with like delusional positivity. You just need to give your brain a different prediction. You know, a workout always feels good afterwards. I'm actually going to feel amazing. I'm probably going to have more fun at that party than I thought I was.
本身。我们一直在做这些预测。这次锻炼会很糟糕。我在这个聚会上会非常焦虑。我今天必须做的这件事会让我精疲力竭。通常情况下，一旦我们的大脑相信了这一点，就很难证明它是错的。你不需要用那种妄想式的积极心态来取代这些想法。你只需要给你的大脑一个不同的预测。你知道，锻炼后总是感觉很好。我实际上会感觉很棒。我可能会在那次聚会上比我想象的玩得更开心。
And if not, I'll just leave. You know, a busy day actually sometimes leaves me feeling energized. You are essentially giving your brain another outcome to look for, another expectation to consider. Tell yourself first what you want to expect or what you want the outcome to be and then work back from there. And your brain pays attention to evidence that supports your original expectation, even if at the beginning it feels forced. This is the same thing with the placebo effect. You say, this medication is going to make me feel better. Your brain searches for evidence that you do feel better. And you can do this for these examples as well. Secondly,
如果不是这样，我就离开。你知道，忙碌的一天有时实际上让我感到精力充沛。你本质上是在给你的大脑提供另一个可以期待的结果，另一个可以考虑的期望。先告诉自己你想要什么期望，或者你想要什么结果，然后从那里反推。你的大脑会关注支持你最初期望的证据，即使在开始时感觉很勉强。安慰剂效应也是如此。你说，这种药物会让我感觉更好。你的大脑会寻找你确实感觉更好的证据。你也可以在这些例子中这样做。其次，
you can create your own placebo cues. If our brain learns through conditioning that certain objects, environments, rituals predict a particular feeling or a particular state, we can build those associations for ourselves. If you say this type of music always gets me hyped, eating this specific breakfast always gives me more energy. I always have a more productive day after I exercise. This outfit makes people see me as more confident. You start to believe it. And those cues start to become psychological shortcuts for the feeling that you want, which is to feel good, to feel confident, to feel healthy, to feel happy. You wear the dress and because you've previously always said, this always makes me feel confident. People always treat me really well when I wear this. I always
你可以创造自己的安慰剂线索。如果我们的大脑通过条件反射学习到某些物体、环境、仪式预示着某种特定的感觉或特定的状态，我们就可以为自己建立这些联想。如果你说这种音乐总是让我兴奋，吃这种特定的早餐总是给我更多的能量。我锻炼后总是会有更高效的一天。这套衣服让人们觉得我更自信。你开始相信它。这些线索开始成为你想要的那种感觉的心理捷径，即感觉良好、感觉自信、感觉健康、感觉快乐。你穿上那件衣服，因为你之前总是说，这总是让我感到自信。我穿这件衣服时，人们总是对我很好。我总是
feel great. You're going to start creating those situations for yourself more because you want to support your initial belief or your initial claim. I did this personally with my brown noise playlist. I was like, I cannot focus. I need something that's going to cue me into focus. And I convinced myself that every time I listen to brown noise, I worked better. Whether I actually did or not, I now do work better when I play it because my brain has been queued. And sometimes it's difficult to get past that initial hurdle of like you kind of know you're tricking yourself.
感觉很棒。你会开始为自己创造更多这样的情况，因为你想支持你最初的信念或最初的主张。我个人用我的棕色噪音播放列表做过这件事。我当时想，我无法集中注意力。我需要一些东西来提示我集中注意力。我让自己相信，每次我听棕色噪音时，我的工作效率都会更高。无论我是否真的做到了，现在当我播放它时，我的工作效率确实更高了，因为我的大脑已经得到了提示。有时很难跨越那种你有点知道自己在欺骗自己的最初障碍。
But what you will find is that after enough repetition, your brain is very gullible. And it's very easy to believe what you continuously tell yourself. I think the final way that we can use the placebo effect in our favor, knowing every Everything we know about how belief literally shapes biology, physiology, psychology, and our emotions is vivid visualization. This is a tip I got from Dr. David Hamilton. He wrote the book, The Joy of Actually Giving a Fuck. The other book he wrote that I feel like is really, really good if you like more of the
但你会发现，经过足够的重复，你的大脑是非常容易受骗的。而且很容易相信你不断告诉自己的事情。我认为我们可以利用安慰剂效应为自己服务的最后一种方法，了解我们所知道的一切关于信念如何真正塑造生物学、生理学、心理学和我们的情绪，那就是生动的可视化。这是我从大卫·汉密尔顿博士那里得到的建议。他写了《The Joy of Actually Giving a Fuck》这本书。他写的另一本书，我觉得如果你喜欢更多关于
spiritual psychology is why Woo Woo works. And he specifically focuses on the mind, body, biochemistry connection, which is essentially what we've been speaking about for this entire episode. And what he said was that when we can visualize and see with full clarity the future that we want and we believe it's possible and we believe that what we are doing is working and we can truly like see it in our mind's eye, we are more likely to work towards that thing and we are more likely to collect evidence that what we want is working for us and this will motivate us even more. It's very similar to the psychology of The more detail you add, the more your dream feels real and possible, which means the less
精神心理学的内容，那本书真的非常非常好，叫《Why Woo Woo Works》。他专门关注身心生物化学的联系，这本质上就是我们这一整集一直在谈论的内容。他说，当我们能够以完全清晰的方式可视化并看到我们想要的未来，并且我们相信它是可能的，我们相信我们正在做的事情是有效的，并且我们真的可以在脑海中看到它，我们就更有可能朝着那个目标努力，我们也更有可能收集证据证明我们想要的东西对我们有效，这将进一步激励我们。这与心理学非常相似。你添加的细节越多，你的梦想就感觉越真实和可能，这意味着你越
dissuaded you will become, the more proactive you will be, the more confidence you will have, the greater likelihood that the thing you imagined all along happening will happen. Manifestation and the placebo effect, the psychological underlines are, and this is going to sound same, basically identical. It really is just belief and how belief influences us in ways that we still don't understand on a tangible physical level to basically create a reality for ourselves that we want. Again, this is not advice for medical conditions. When it comes to diseases, illnesses, like eventually, like we said, the placebo effect wears out. Real treatment. scientifically investigated treatment is always going to be better. You cannot cure yourself
不会被劝阻，你会越积极主动，你会越自信，你一直想象的事情发生的可能性就越大。显化和安慰剂效应，其心理基础是，这听起来可能一样，基本上是相同的。它确实只是信念，以及信念如何以我们仍然无法在有形的物理层面上理解的方式影响我们，从而基本上为我们自己创造我们想要的现实。再说一次，这不是针对医疗状况的建议。当涉及到疾病、病痛时，就像我们说的，安慰剂效应最终会消失。真正的治疗，经过科学调查的治疗总是会更好。你不能治愈自己
through your mindset alone. Belief cannot take away cancerous cells. It cannot take away chronic pain. It cannot eliminate a disease of your body. But for things separate to this that are more about self-belief in a personal success and a personal goal and a personal manifestation area, it is incredibly powerful. Reality is about 50% perception. And so change your perception, you're better able to change the part of your reality that you can control. And you can change your perception by what you initially feed yourself about the likelihood or the chances of interventions that you are putting into your life being successful. So that, my friends, is our episode on the psychology and history of the placebo effect with a little bit at the end about how you can use this in your favor.
仅仅通过你的心态。信念无法消除癌细胞。它无法消除慢性疼痛。它无法消除你身体的疾病。但对于除此之外的，更多关于个人成功、个人目标和个人显化领域的自我信念的事情，它是极其强大的。现实大约有50%是感知。所以改变你的感知，你就更有能力改变你所能控制的那部分现实。你可以通过你最初喂养自己的关于你生活中所采取的干预措施成功可能性的信息来改变你的感知。所以，我的朋友们，这就是我们关于安慰剂效应的心理学和历史的一集，最后还有一点关于你如何利用它为自己服务的内容。
placebo continues to be fascinating researchers. Like we still can't fully explain this mechanism. I've given you the best explanations that we have so far, but it's a big research focus for those who study mind-body connection, and it's constantly evolving. So we're going to see so much more of it in the future. There is a mechanism underlying all this we really just don't understand yet. Again, it's unethical for it to replace real treatments long term.
安慰剂继续让研究人员着迷。就像我们仍然无法完全解释这种机制。我已经给了你们我们目前为止最好的解释，但对于那些研究身心联系的人来说，这是一个巨大的研究重点，而且它在不断发展。所以我们将来会看到更多。这一切背后确实有一个我们目前还不了解的机制。再说一次，让它长期取代真正的治疗是不道德的。
So it's hard to understand when exactly the effects start to wear off and why, but it's a very good way scientifically of measuring what actually works biologically and what actually works psychologically in a systematic way. And without placebo trials, placebo effects, control groups, we would not have some of the life-saving like medications and treatments that we do that save lives literally every single minute of every single day. So that's, I think, everything we need to know about the placebo effect. Thank you to our researcher Libby Corbett for her. her assistance with this episode. Now, this episode, as I said, was part of our larger debunking
所以很难理解效果究竟何时开始消失以及为什么消失，但从科学上讲，这是一种以系统方式衡量什么在生物学上真正有效，什么在心理学上真正有效的非常好方法。如果没有安慰剂试验、安慰剂效应、对照组，我们就不会拥有一些每天每时每刻都在拯救生命的救命药物和治疗方法。所以，我认为这就是我们需要了解的关于安慰剂效应的一切。感谢我们的研究员利比·科比特对本集提供的协助。现在，正如我所说，这一集是我们更大的揭秘
psychology series. So if you like episodes like more myth-busty historical type episodes where maybe we reference Benjamin Franklin and things like that, I'm going to leave a link to the full playlist below. We cover everything from personality test to dopamine, stockard syndrome, Freud. There's actually so much there. So I hope you go and check it out. Make sure as well that you leave a five-star review if you feel called to do so. If you enjoyed this episode, Send it to a friend. Follow us on Instagram. There are so many other ways to connect. I'm going to leave a link in the description. But until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. Lisa, tell them about our new show. We have a new podcast. It's called Don't Lie to Me. I'm Lexi Youanu. We're two best friends, 22 years apart, but so close at heart. And I'm Lisa Di Giulio, the old one, which means we have wildly different references, occasionally different at the
心理学系列的一部分。所以如果你喜欢像这种更具神话色彩的历史类剧集，也许我们提到了本杰明·富兰克林之类的事情，我会在下面留下完整播放列表的链接。我们涵盖了从性格测试到多巴胺、斯德哥尔摩综合症、弗洛伊德等所有内容。那里实际上有很多东西。所以我希望你去看看。如果你觉得有必要，请务必留下五星好评。如果你喜欢这一集，发给朋友。在Instagram上关注我们。还有很多其他联系方式。我会在描述中留下一个链接。但下次见之前，注意安全，保持善良，善待自己。我们很快就会再谈。丽莎，告诉他们我们的新节目。我们有一个新的播客。它叫《别对我撒谎》。我是莱克西·尤阿努。我们是两个最好的朋友，相差22岁，但心却很近。我是丽莎·迪·朱利奥，年纪大的那个，这意味着我们有截然不同的参考资料，偶尔会有不同的
opinions, and at this point in my 50s, I've lived it all. Now in my 30s, being the founder of new shoes, good taste is my business. Listen on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Melissa Jeltson, host of the What Happened to Her podcast. We're kicking off the season with the Sandra Birchmore story, a case the police rode off as a suicide in a snowstorm. Her family never bought it, and the man they suspected wore a badge. You never know who that devil is because he's wearing in disguise. Sometimes it's a police uniform.
观点，在50多岁的这个时候，我已经经历了一切。现在30多岁，作为新鞋的创始人，好品味是我的生意。在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。我是梅丽莎·杰尔森，《What Happened to Her》播客的主持人。我们以桑德拉·伯奇莫尔的故事开启本季，这是一个警察在暴风雪中将其定性为自杀的案件。她的家人从未相信，而他们怀疑的那个人戴着徽章。你永远不知道那个魔鬼是谁，因为他伪装了。有时是警察制服。
And you can get access to all episodes 100% ad-free with an I-Heart True Crime Plus subscription exclusively on Apple Podcasts, available only to IHeart True Crime Plus subscribers. So don't wait. Head to Apple Podcasts. Search for I-Heart True Crime Plus and subscribe today. Hi, this is Kylie Breakman. Angel Geratana. Jeremy Colhain, Patrick McDonald.
你可以通过I-Heart True Crime Plus订阅在Apple Podcasts上独家获得所有剧集的100%无广告访问权限，仅供IHeart True Crime Plus订阅者使用。所以不要等待。前往Apple Podcasts。搜索I-Heart True Crime Plus并立即订阅。嗨，我是凯莉·布雷克曼。安吉尔·杰拉塔纳。杰里米·科尔海恩，帕特里克·麦克唐纳。
And we're the hosts of The Artists on Artists on. Artists on Artists Podcast. The Improvised Character Comedy Podcast where each week a new panel of artists discuss their craft. Join us for a panel of Eurovision participants. And we do a little Halloween sometimes. Does the Pope dress up?
我们是《Artists on Artists on Artists》播客的主持人。这是一个即兴角色喜剧播客，每周都有一个新的艺术家小组讨论他们的手艺。加入我们，参加一个欧洲歌唱大赛参与者的小组讨论。我们有时也会做一点万圣节内容。教皇会打扮吗？
He winks on Halloween. He gets right up next to the microphone. I hear you can almost hear the eyelashes hit each other. You never seen Italy so quiet as when the Pope gets up to wink on Halloween. Listen to Artists on Artists on Artists every Thursday on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Lacey Mosley, author, actor, stand-up comedian, creator, and host of Scam Goddess Podcast.
他在万圣节眨眼。他直接凑到麦克风旁边。我听说你几乎可以听到睫毛撞击的声音。你从未见过意大利像教皇在万圣节眨眼时那样安静。每周四在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Artists on Artists on Artists》。我是莱西·莫斯利，作家、演员、单口喜剧演员、创作者和《Scam Goddess》播客的主持人。
The True Crime Comedy Podcasts, all about robbery, fraud, and those who practice it. Each week, I bring on an amazing guest. Ooh, I scammed them. What? I can talk to you for an hour. You're a generational yapper, like me. That's why I had to make yapping a job. And now you can catch full episodes of my show on YouTube.
这是一档关于抢劫、欺诈以及那些实施欺诈的人的真实犯罪喜剧播客。每周，我都会请来一位很棒的嘉宾。哦，我骗了他们。什么？我可以和你聊一个小时。你和我一样是个滔滔不绝的人。这就是为什么我必须把这种滔滔不绝变成一份工作。现在你可以在YouTube上观看我节目的完整剧集。
Start listening to Scam Goddess on the IHeart Radio. app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. I'm Carrie Champion, and in this new season of biggest rivalries of all-time podcast, we take you back to the very first rivalry of the WNBA. The Comets were to real deal. I mean, come on. The Liberty was just tough. Oh, God.
开始在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Scam Goddess》。我是凯莉·钱皮恩，在《史上最大竞争对手》播客的新一季中，我们将带你回到WNBA的第一次竞争。彗星队是真正的交易。我的意思是，得了吧。自由人队只是很强硬。哦，天哪。
The New York Liberty versus the Houston Comets. When we hit the floor, it was hot, heated, fights, elbows, competition, trash talking. Who is the better team? People live, but numbers don't. Listen to biggest rivalries of all time on the IHard Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
纽约自由人队对阵休斯顿彗星队。当我们踏上球场时，气氛火热、激烈，有打架、肘击、竞争、垃圾话。谁是更好的球队？人们会撒谎，但数字不会。在IHard Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《史上最大竞争对手》。这是一个IHart播客。保证是人类制作的。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。